the movie is set in the year 1964 and is
based on a real-life practice it existed
among the Irish Roman Catholic Community
at the time people sent the so-called
Fallen women into a popular Asylum
called the Magdalene claiming that it is
for their Redemption among these women
is the protagonist of the movie Margaret
on the joyous occasion of a wedding
party she is inappropriately assaulted
by her own cousin in a dark room while
the party is in full swing downstairs
among the loud celebration none of the
guests hear her cries for help after he
finally leaves her alone Margaret
gathers the courage to tell her family
about what happened but what happens
next is something she would never have
imagined in her wildest dreams they put
the blame on her instead claiming that
she is a seductress who just wants
attention the very next morning she is
driven off to the Magdalene Asylum
without any warning the second
protagonist is also a young woman named
Bernadette who's only its sin is being
beautiful she is kicked out of her
boarding school and is sent to the
Asylum overnight after her teacher
accuses her of being flirtatious
somewhere else there is a third woman
named Rose who has a child out of
wedlock her parents force her to put the
baby up for adoption as soon as he is
born and Rose herself is taken to none
other than Magdalene the entire Asylum
is filled with women with similar
stories who have been sent to live there
indefinitely what are you in for I said
I don't like making sandwiches I did
long division I murdered my husband on
the first day the three women are
introduced to Christina she is a little
slow and shows signs of mental
disability but is rather friendly she
excitedly Whispers to Rose about her son
who comes along with Christina's sister
to the asylum's gate sometimes because
she is not allowed to talk to them she
only waves at them happily every time
while clutching her pendant as it turns
out the main task assigned to the women
here is doing the laundry which the
Asylum does business in it is a
laborious task without the help of
washing machines and it takes a toll on
the women's bodies it is especially
difficult for Rose who has given birth
barely days ago but the regime in
Magdalene is unforgiving and she must
follow every rule that is set without
expecting any special treatment the
women start adapting to their new way of
life accepting their fate for being born
female then one morning when a nun comes
into the women's shared room to wake
them up she finds that a girl has gone
missing this incident causes the place
to change from how it usually operates
as the nuns are kept busy in search of
the missing girl Margaret wants to take
this opportunity to escape home but the
same night she plans her escape the
missing girl is dragged into the shared
room by her father she had run back home
but her family did not want anything to
do with her her father also does not
care about her pleas nor her cries and
instead threatens to [__] her if she
tries to run away again assuming this is
exactly how she would be treated if she
went back Margaret dismisses her plan
the next morning the women go on about
their usual tasks of collecting dirty
laundry from the delivery men and
returning them washed clothes they
noticed a new face among the men and try
to make a conversation before finding
out he has quite the foul personality he
bad mouths all the women in Magdalene
and even makes inappropriate advances
towards Bernadette he even yells
derogatory things in fortnite lobbies
even so nothing can be done about his
behavior because when Bernadette goes to
the Head nun to complain she is punished
instead for having a loose character
frustrated by the way they are treated
inside the Asylum and by the society she
becomes determined to leave the place by
any means possible the next morning she
begins her plan to seduce the delivery
man and run away with him however the
plan does not go as well as she had
thought because some simple kissing is
not enough to convince him to elope with
her so she takes things a step further
and lets him see her private parts this
makes the delivery man agree to help her
in his moment of lust whoa goodness me
look at them prophets Bernadette's near
perfect scheme is almost ruined when an
old woman of the Asylum finds her
exposing herself to the delivery man she
immediately runs to the woman and begs
her not to tell the head none but she
refuses to listen only when Bernadette
threatens to kill herself does she
hesitate and temporarily give up on the
idea that night the delivery man keeps
his promise to Bernadette and sneaks
into the Asylum to open the back door
and let her Escape but just when
Bernadette desperately runs through the
hallways of the building the delivery
man starts having second thoughts maybe
it's my back door that I want to open he
changes his mind right before Bernadette
reaches the door and closes the lock
again she begs him to open the door but
the man is not ready to risk his job to
help a girl he barely knows so he
silently leaves the way he came but this
leaves Bernadette to face her punishment
for attempting to escape she struggles
and screams but the nuns firmly capture
her and violently cut off her hair
before leaving her all bloody years past
as the women of the Asylum are stuck
doing the same task every day without
rest until finally the Asylum brings in
washing machines which makes the job
easier to celebrate the nuns hold a
sadistic contest they force all the
Fallen women to line up naked to compare
things like who has the biggest breasts
or who is the hairiest these nuns love
buns this event deeply scars crispina
and affects her sense of self-worth
tired of living her life in a loop she
decides to sleep with a soaked nightgown
on hoping she would get the flu and die
but to her disbelief Margaret reveals to
her that young people cannot die from a
simple flu right then crispina discovers
something else that makes her frantic
her pendant that she holds so close to
her heart has gone missing Margaret
manages to soothe her cries by promising
to find it for her but after losing her
precious Keepsake she is determined to
kill herself even if it means committing
a grave sin and going to hell that she
ties up her bed sheets into a noose and
tries to hang herself inside the
bathroom thankfully she is discovered by
Margaret and she along with other women
are able to rescue crispina in time they
console her late into the night before
eventually going to bed the next morning
the Magdalene Asylum is having a film
made about itself for the sake of the
movie The Nuns and the priests posed the
Asylum as a joyous Place full of
laughter and exciting activities while
inmates are swept up in the change of
scenery from their usual laborious days
they genuinely begin to feel happy
without having to pretend for the camera
all except for Margaret Margaret is in
great turmoil because this morning she
had accidentally discovered the priest
taking advantage of crispina's
simple-minded nature as he convinced her
to give him a sexual favor Margaret's
already weak trust in the Asylum
shatters completely it is unbelievable
that she has to place her faith in these
nuns and Priests to cleanse her of her
sin while they themselves ourselves are
the biggest sinners in Magdalene unable
to stand still and do nothing she runs
off to the Back Garden to pick up some
leaves from a plant she is careful not
to touch it and wraps the leaves up in a
handkerchief while she spots an unlocked
door she cautiously steps out the door
and sees the scenery in front of her she
is finally out of the Asylum she could
Escape right now if she wants to but for
some unknown reason she doesn't Margaret
even lets go of the car that was ready
to give her a lift and goes back inside
with a newfound resolve that night after
dinner she heads to the communal
sleeping room before the rest of the
women and turns the entire Place upside
down to search for crispina's pendant
when she finds it hidden among
Bernadette's belongings she goes mad
with rage she attacks Bernadette as soon
as she enters the room and starts
shouting curses at her but crispina who
is the victim of her theft is just happy
to get her pendant back the next morning
Margaret is the one who is put in charge
of the priest's law laundry she
dutifully puts his dirty clothes inside
the washing machine but then sneakily
dumps in the leaves that she had
collected the other day a few days later
it is some sort of a festival the
inmates are dressed up in good clothes
and are let out of the Asylum to parade
around the town they are herded Along by
the nuns while the priests lead the
parade the sound of bagpipes is loud and
sharp as the onlooker's eye the inmates
as if they are some fascinating
creatures the procession comes to a stop
at a wide field all the people belonging
to Magdalene and the Common People
gather together to listen to the priest
as he recites Bible verses while the
priest is giving a speech Margaret
cannot keep her smile contained because
her plan is bearing fruit right before
her eyes the priest soon grows
uncomfortable in his clothes as the
itchiness in his body slowly grows
before becoming unbearable he shouts and
screams as he frantically rips off all
the layers of his clothes one after
another until he is completely naked in
front of the large Gathering of people
he runs off to the fields being unable
to withstand the violent red rashes that
have spread all around his body but it's
too late the township has already seen
his micropenis but right then crispina
also begins to feel itchiness on her
inner thighs foolishly she tries to ask
the nuns for help but they certainly
tell her to sit down quietly it is
obvious to everybody and Margaret even
more so that the priest was entangled in
an intimate affair with crispina right
before the ceremony Christina who sees
the nuns indifference and the priest's
shameful behavior is unable to hold her
emotions in she starts shouting you are
not a man of God repeatedly the nuns
cannot restrain her because they have to
uphold their image so they can only
watch as she continues screaming after
getting back to Magdalene crispina is
immediately sent off to a mental
hospital to silence her from revealing
the abuse she suffered at the hands of
the priest as expect affected crispina
doesn't want to go but her struggle is
meaningless as the doctors come to
violently drag her out despite her
miserable pleas days pass and it is the
day of celebrating Christmas now the
inmates and the nuns gather together in
a room to watch a Cheesy religious movie
right when the movie ends Margaret's
brother appears inside the room he has
come with their father's letter to get
her out of the Asylum Margaret feels
unreal that she could just leave this
easily with a simple letter she is
Overjoyed but also frustrated that it
took four years for her brother to come
she sharply walks out of Magdalene with
her head held high refusing to give way
for the head nun she opts to get down on
her knees and start praying in the
middle of the hallway which forces the
head nun to step aside instead an
unknown amount of time passes by a few
days maybe a few years the life at the
Asylum is as usual with new fallen women
coming in and old Fallen women in their
Death Beds and the nuns continue you to
exploit the inmates seeing a baby
getting adopted from this place Rose is
reminded of her own child she realizes
that his birthday is coming soon and
wants to send him a card she goes to the
Head nuns office to make her request but
the nun does not care for a single word
she has to say and is too busy searching
for the key of a locker the nun who is
rummaging through the room orders Rose
to begin searching as well the key is
very important as it opens the locker
where the nun keeps all her money when
she hears this Rose freezes and doesn't
grab the key which she is already
located under a cupboard she apologizes
for being unable to find it and steps
out of the room the same day after
witnessing the death of an old inmate
who is stuck inside the Asylum for over
40 years Bernadette grows fearful for
her future no one is going to come save
her like Margaret so the only choices
left for her is to escape or to rot in
this place until she dies that night
hardened with a new resolve Bernadette
convinced Rose to escape with her they
used the bed frame to break the door of
their bedroom the loud noise wakes up
the other inmates but they all pretend
to have not seen a thing and go back to
sleep with their loud footsteps echoing
through the building they run to the
Head nuns office to search for the gate
key when they finally find it hidden
inside a drawer the head nuns suddenly
appears and snatches the key right out
of Bernadette's hands and proceeds to
beat her but she is able to overpower
the old nun and threatens to Slit her
throat with scissors even at a
disadvantage that had none stubbornly
refuses to break her hold of the key and
the two women struggle back and forth
the deadlock is broken by Rose who hands
over the key of the money Locker in
exchange for the key of the gate that
had none who's Greed for money is well
known lets go of the gay key at last the
two of them finally managed to escape
the Asylum while fending off other nuns
who come to block their way they run
through the fields and jump over wooden
gates without stopping or looking back
until they finally reach town there they
approach a female hair stylist to ask
for help and she kindly gives them new
clothes and some money with her help
Rose gets on a bus to Liverpool where
she wishes to start a new life while
Bernadette remains there to work as an
apprentice hairstylist at the salon the
movie ends there as they tell us what
happened to the women after leaving
Magdalene Bernadette eventually moved to
Scotland to open her own salon and got
married and divorced three times Rose
also got married and had two daughters
but she only managed to find her son 33
years after he was taken from her
Margaret never married and became a
primary school teacher and eventually an
assistant headmistress Christina whose
real name was Harriet died of anorexia
in the mental institution at the age of
24. subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching